Mm,
so when we sleep and we have an empty
stomach,
then the activity,
the contractile activity of our gut
changes to a very unique pattern.
It's a 90 minute cycle,
very powerful wastes of contractions
migrate from the Esophagus all the way
down to the nfr,
large intestine,
and they move very slowly.
They have been.
So this has been referred to as the
intestinal housekeeper that sort of
cleans the gut from any residue that's
present,
um,
and the rhythm for that is generated by
the brain.
So it's dependent on the input of the
Vegas nerve on the,
on the second brain in the gut.
And this has been something that also
should occur when during daytime,
when I'm in between meals or when our
stomach and intestinal system is,
is empty.
However,
with this sort of modern habit of
snacking in between meals,
um,
so a lot of people don't have that
during the day,
but have it during sleep.
If you add the microbes into this now,
um,
it's,
it's quite likely I'm not really proven
it.
I mean,
the microbes obey some kind of a
circadian rhythm by themselves.
So the different drink,
sleep and during daytime,
um,
but it's,
it's quite plausible to assume that this
powerful waves that sort of cleans
everything out will also affect the
microbes,
the composition of the microbes because
if we don't have it,
so people that don't have that for some,
for some reason they will develop
abnormal.
I'm quoting cessation for example,
of the small bowel was a lot of microbes
that don't really belong there.
So clearly an important role in
regulating the populations and the
regional distribution of these microbes
now got what happens during sleep,
so during,
during rem sleep,
um,
and so on behalf
in a lot of activity going on within the
autonomic nervous system,
circuits within the brain and the
signals is being sent to the gut.
So our bodies inhibited,
um,
but not,
not our intestinal activity.
So in,
in many ways,
emotions they received.
Usually there'd be experienced visually
in our dreams,
have their mirror image in terms of
God's activity,
contractions,
secretions.
And again,
I mean,
just like everything that goes on within
the brain emotionally always is
reflected.
Just like our facial expression reflects
our emotions.
Everything reflects our emotional state,
either waking time asleep,
time at the gut level,
and the Micros who live in that
environment or affected by it.
So it's,
it's an area that's not studied in great
detail,
but probably very important for an
understanding of how the microbes,
the gut and the brain interact,
um,
and maintain health.
So sleep is a very important ingredient
for,
for health regulation of the immune
system,
but for the also regulation of the,
um,
of gut function and particularly got
microbial,
um,
integrity and wellbeing.
We know quite a bit about what happens
during sleep and during dreaming in
psychoanalysis,
this is a big window into our emotional
lives.
So Union or in Freudian psychoanalysis
have spent a lot of time interpreting
dreams and getting an access to this,
to this process.
A big portion is probably the processing
and constantly dation of memories that
have been experienced in the day.
Many of these of these memories have a
gut feeling components because every
time we have an emotion during the data
is always a counterpart at the gut
level.
That is then through the sensory
pathways,
goes back to the brain.
We may not experience it during the
daytime,
but it's encoded in this vast database
within the brain.
So what happens then during sleep,
there's this retrieval and then
processing consolidation of these
memories,
including all the guts feelings that are
associated with,
with those experiences that we had
during the day.
I think it's a very important point to
emphasize that emotions
have an integrated component of got
activity and got feelings regardless if
we feel it like the butterflies in the
stomach or the knot in the stomach,
every emotion has a component that the
brain engages got activity and that's
being reported back to the brain.
So you have to look at an emotion really
is a circular process within the brain,
gut access,
and um,
during sleep and during dreaming.
It's almost certainly a consultation and
processing of these myriad of,
of gut feelings that are generated
throughout the day.